Nous voulons dédire ce passage qui nous a présenté la condescendance de Dieu, la grâce de Dieu, tout de suite après la rébellion de l'humanité, tout de suite après la chute de l'humanité.
Et avant de considérer les textes en lui-même, ce qu'on fera bientôt, je pense qu'à chaque fois qu'on rentre dans un nouvel chapitre, c'est important pour nous de nous rappeler l'importance de l'ordre et la structure, par exemple, de la confession des foies ou des théologies systématiques, car il y a une intentionnalité didatique et importante qui cherche à honorer ce qui est l'objectif de la Bible.
Donc la Bible a là pour objectif de nous faire comprendre ces grands points de rédemption.
Les festins de la théologie, on s'en rappelle très bien, c'est d'étudier Dieu dans son être, dans ses trois personnes, dans ses vertus.
Et donc ce qu'on a fait comme point de départ, c'était d'étudier avant tout l'autorité des écritures.
Car même si l'objectif suprême et l'objectif qui va perdurer pour toute l'éternité, c'est de connaître Dieu et progresser dans la connaissance de ces dieux, dont les vertus sont infinies.
Donc l'amabilité n'a pas de fin.
Nous devons en tant qu'être humain être sûrs d'où nous pouvons trouver une source fiable et précise à propos des dieux.
Donc on a compris que l'être humain de soi-même ne peut jamais, même s'il peut avoir quelques idées correctes des dieux, il ne peut jamais s'assurer que ces idées des dieux sont correctes, à moins que Dieu lui-même ne les confirme.
Et on a considéré l'importance que la Bible soit une seule, que la source des connaissances fiables des dieux soit une seule pour cette unité.
Et donc on a considéré l'autorité et l'inspiration des écritures, c'était le premier chapitre ou le point de départ.
Donc le but de la confession c'est de nous convaincre que si nous pouvons connaître Dieu et nous voulons avoir une connaissance fiable de Dieu et une connaissance pertinente pour ce qui concerne notre réconciliation avec Dieu,
car il ne suffit pas de connaître Dieu ou connaître à propos de Dieu, nous voulons connaître Dieu de manière relationnelle, de manière à être réconcilié avec lui.
Nous n'avons qu'é la Bible comme source fiable, suffisante et parfaite.
Donc ensuite on a considéré notamment l'objectif principal de la théologie, donc la nature, l'être de Dieu, ses attributs, etc.
Et là on était dans les festons de la théologie, contempler Dieu dans sa beauté.
Ça nous a aussi protégés, et c'est didatique et intentionnel, en commençant par Dieu.
On est non seulement dans la contemplation de l'objet suprême de notre joie, nous sommes aussi dans la contemplation des réalités qui sont tellement clairement révélées dans la parole de Dieu,
qui nous protègent dans notre condition actuelle, lorsque nous nous approcherions des doctrines un peu plus difficiles,
ou qui défient un peu plus notre carnalité, ou notre tendance philosophique de vouloir tout expliquer ou tout comprendre.
que lorsqu'on touchera par exemple la doctrine de l'harmonisation entre la souveraineté des dieux, la responsabilité de l'homme, ou l'élection des dieux,
ceux qui ont été préordonnés à l'enfer, etc.
On soit protégés par des déclarations très claires de la parole de Dieu, qui nous enseignent clairement que Dieu est sang, que Dieu est juste,
que Dieu est bon, que Dieu possède une droiture, une pureté infinie, qu'il ne peut même pas contempler les mal.
Donc avant de douter de la révélation des dieux, de l'intentionnalité des dieux, de la parole des dieux,
nous devons douter de notre incapacité, de notre carnalité, car on a commencé par les attributs des dieux.
Donc ça nous protège pour toute la suite de la révélation biblique.
Ensuite on a considéré Dieu non seulement dans son être, mais Dieu dans ses œuvres.
Et avant de considérer proprement la manière dont Dieu a fait les choses,
le troisième chapitre l'a touché au plan éternel des dieux, donc les descents éternels des dieux.
C'est des descents qui sont en seuls, en grand plan A, mais qui comprend plusieurs sous-decents.
C'est-à-dire Dieu n'a jamais un plan B, aucune chose ne se passe dans l'histoire qui puisse surprendre Dieu.
Et donc ça nous protège d'arriver à quelques conclusions précipitées et équivoques,
quand on voit par exemple la chute.
La chute a été quelque chose qui s'est passé sous la permission de Dieu,
car Dieu dans sa gouvernance suprême et dans sa sagesse infinie,
il avait un but supérieur à travers tout ça.
Et donc Dieu n'a pas été pris par surprise à la chute.
Les plans, comme on verra aujourd'hui,
de nous sauvés par Jésus-Christ,
et que Dieu les fils des liens, les médiateurs entre l'humanité et Dieu,
ils comprenaient la chute de l'homme.
Donc on a considéré les décents parfaits des dieux,
qui sont fondés sur sa souveraineté,
et sont fondés sur sa bonté, sa sagesse, etc., son omniscience.
Et donc, une fois ayant considéré cet aspect d'un dieu
qui planifie parfaitement toutes les choses,
Dieu va mettre en exécution toutes les choses.
Et il les fait d'abord par cette création,
et par la providence.
Ce sont les chapitres qu'on a vus par la suite.
Cette providence par laquelle Dieu maintient toutes les choses en existence,
Dieu en interagissant bien présent dans l'univers,
et aussi par les lois qu'il lui-même a créées pour que cet univers fonctionne.
Et Dieu, il a créé l'être humain,
après avoir créé toutes les choses,
l'homme comme couronne de la création.
Donc on a vu les œuvres de Dieu,
la providence,
et notamment l'homme comme couronne de cette création.
sauf que cet état des béatitudes originales n'a pas été réjoui par l'homme pour longtemps.
Donc à partir de là,
en ayant considéré toutes les choses qu'il a créées,
les êtres invisibles, les anges,
et ensuite l'être humain,
et avant ça toute la création,
donc on a considéré la chute.
Et quand on a considéré la chute,
on a constaté cette condition tragique,
on a constaté au moment l'explication,
ou surtout plutôt l'explication
de cette question qui est la question la plus présente pour l'humanité aujourd'hui,
le fait que nous sommes une race déchue,
quelque chose qui est empirique et universelle,
et la grande question,
d'où est venue cette condition
qui est partagée par chaque individu
qui compose cette race.
Et donc on a considéré
notre liaison au péché original,
original d'Adam,
notre représentant,
et à partir de là,
on a constaté aussi les conséquences
de ces péchés.
En contemplant cette condition tragique de l'homme,
cette illustration
où nous pouvons voir
chez chaque être humain
quels qui restent des noblesses
qui sont apparemment
cachés derrière
les manifestations plus fréquentes
de notre carnalité,
de notre bestialité.
C'est comme si on était devant les ruines
d'un grand château,
d'un grand empire ancien
qui communique un jour
ces châteaux,
ces palais étaient très beaux
et un roi a habité ici.
Dieu habitant
au centre de nos vies,
à notre cœur.
Donc ça, c'est la réalité
pour chaque individu
et pour toute la race humaine.
Et cette réalité
de l'être humain,
notamment non-réginéré,
se trouve,
ou fait que l'homme se trouve
dans une condition
de dépravation totale,
donc corrompu
depuis les cœurs,
rebelle contre Dieu,
séparé des dieux
depuis son cœur,
désintéressé des dieux,
ennemi des dieux,
en fouillant de la présence des dieux
par nature
et par désir personnel,
corrompu,
et sa totale incapacité,
dépravation totale,
une fois que le cœur est corrompu,
toutes les affluents du cœur
qui composent
l'anthropologie humaine
sont aussi tachés
des corruptions.
Et donc,
il y a l'aspect
de la coupabilité,
de l'expérience
des corruptions
empiriques,
et il y a aussi
cet aspect
d'incapacité
de sortir
de cette condition.
OK ?
Et une fois
qu'on a trouvé l'homme
dans cette condition,
par les récits
notamment de la chute,
on a vu
que de manière
immédiate
et automatique,
l'être humain
a tourné les deux
contre Dieu,
il a voulu
se cacher des dieux,
se justifier
au lieu de confesser
ses fautes,
et on a vu
de manière très
surprenante
par la grâce des dieux
que Dieu lui-même
va prendre l'initiative
d'aller chercher
l'homme
et d'établir
un nouveau pacte.
OK ?
Donc,
quand on considère
la connexion
dans l'ordre
de chacun
de ces chapitres,
j'espère que vous
puissiez voir
cet intérêt
à garder
et préserver
Dieu
dans sa
sainteté
absolue,
dans ses vertus
absolues,
et
exercer
une discipline
envers nous
et nos esprits
corrompus
à nous mettre
dans notre position
avant de questionner
ou de mettre
en question
la révélation
biblique
ou la condition
dans laquelle
on se trouve.
Et par là,
c'est comme si
on était en train
d'enlever
les sandales
de nos pieds
pour nous approcher
de cette révélation
qui nous touche
plus directement.
Donc,
bien sûr qu'on a étudié
la personne
et les attributs
de la deuxième
personne de la Trinité,
mais nous sommes
en train
de nous approcher
par ces chapitres
de la révélation
du médiateur,
de l'incarnation
de la deuxième
personne de la Trinité
qui est notre
rédempteur.
Et nous faisons
bien
de garder
nos esprits
au bon endroit
dans la contemplation
de la merveille.
Et voilà pourquoi
je renforce
ces points
quand on pense
de manière
très systématique
et voilà
un des dangers
que nous pouvons
retrouver
lorsque nous
nous approchons
de certains thèmes
qui sont sujets
légitimes parfois
des débats théologiques,
d'abord
par la théologie
systématique
qu'est par
la lecture biblique
tout simplement.
car l'avantage
des confessions
des fois
c'est qu'elles
cherchent
dans leur simplicité
de rester
dans une structure
systématique
bien sûr
mais en étant
très accrochées
à la manière
biblique
de développer
ces choses.
Et par là
en fait
on est présenté
à chaque fois
on se retrouve
dans une espèce
de chronologie
biblique
de la théologie
biblique.
c'est comme
une harmonie
un équilibre
un bon équilibre
entre la théologie
systématique
et la théologie
biblique.
Et c'est pour ça
qu'à chaque fois
on fait cet exercice
on commence
la considération
d'un thème
plutôt par
son environnement
biblique
pour après
arriver aux conclusions
ou considérations
des points théologiques.
C'est clair pour vous
ce que je suis en train
de dire ?
Car on a
dans notre parcours
des fois
plusieurs personnes
qui sont exposées
d'abord
au débat théologique
et ça fait un appel
énorme
à notre intérêt
intellectuel.
Et très vite
on peut se laisser porter
par la capacité
la rhétorique
les bons arguments
dans certains camps
sans avoir été exposé
à un autre
et même si on a été
exposé aux deux
ou aux trois
ou aux quatre
la réalité
c'est qu'on aurait fait mieux
d'avoir
une expérience
directe
avec l'environnement
biblique
d'où on tire
ces questions
et ces conclusions.
Je pense que
particulièrement
dans les discussions
sur la théologie
biblique
j'espère que vous
pourriez voir
les résultats
une fois qu'ils ont
fait cet exercice
à nouveau.
D'accord ?
Et voilà pourquoi
on ne peut pas
perdre de vue
pour l'instant
l'importance
immédiate
de la communication
de cette rédemption
de cet espoir
une fois qu'on vient
de sortir
de la contemplation
de la chute.
Nous voici tous
en train de contempler
la chute d'Adam
et Ève
les représentants
de notre race
et son impact
sur nous.
Et la sensation
qu'on a en lisant
la Bible
c'est que maintenant
on n'a plus d'espoir.
C'est fini pour nous
pour notre race
car Dieu
il est Dieu
qui ne peut pas mentir
il a dit
si tu manges
de ces fruits
certainement
en mourant
tu mourras.
Ok ?
Littéralement
selon les textes.
Et la réalité
c'est que oui
l'homme a expérimenté
cette mort radicale
cette mort spirituelle
cette mort physique
mais Dieu
a aussi
pris la décision
dans un certain sens
d'expérimenter
Dieu lui-même
cette mort à notre place
pour pouvoir
nous donner
la vie.
Et c'est l'initiative divine.
Et c'est l'espoir
qu'il a là
un espoir
qui a lieu
dans une structure
d'alliance
comme on verra.
Et donc
nous allons
aujourd'hui
nous concentrer
plus sur la considération
de cet aspect
plutôt
théologie biblique
qu'est théologie
systématique.
Ok ?
Vous êtes avec moi
et donc nous allons
dans un premier moment
considérer
tout simplement
donc je vais faire
la lecture
pour que vous voyez
comment les paragraphes
les paragraphes
des compétences
même s'ils vont
introduire
les bases
et les éléments
théologiques
qui touchent
cette structure
d'alliance.
Je vais vous évoquer
quelques implications.
Donc quand on pense
à la théologie
d'alliance
par la perspective
de la théologie
systématique
nous pensons
non seulement
à la structure
d'une alliance
spécifique
quels sont les éléments
qui doivent la composer
on verra ça après
mais il parle aussi
des médiations
ou des médiateurs
avant que Christ vienne
et ça c'est aussi
intéressant
et important
à considérer.
Il parle aussi
de cette interrelation
entre cette alliance
des grâces
qu'il a fait
avec plusieurs manifestations
des sous-alliances
ou des petites alliances
qu'il a fait
au long de l'histoire
et c'est là
notamment
on va contempler
les grandes discussions
au débat théologique
et bien sûr
quelle est la relation
entre chaque alliance
et son symbole
et comment ça peut jouer
dans la considération
du Nouveau Testament
dans la Nouvelle Alliance
par rapport au symbole
de baptême
et de la Saint-Seine.
Et donc
pour nous
on va plutôt considérer
cette intégration
biblique
de manière biblique
et cette compréhension
même de la notion
d'alliance
par la Bible
avant de considérer
toutes ces implications
théologiques.
Et donc
je vais vous lire
les paragraphes
de la confession
des phoies
pour que vous puissiez
voir que même
si certains
de ces éléments
théologiques
seront évoqués
les langages
ils restent
beaucoup plus
ancrés
et similaires
aux récits bibliques
dans les développements
de la théologie
biblique.
Donc
j'espère
que vous puissiez
évoquer
les chapitres précédents
pendant qu'on lit
ces premiers paragraphes.
Ok ?
Chapitre 7
L'alliance des dieux
avec l'homme
Confession
Baptiste
et Foie
de Londres
Paragraphe 1
du chapitre 7
il dit
Donc là
les termes
Alliances introduit
quels sont
les passages
qui nous viennent
à l'esprit
donc déjà
tout de suite
on rappelle
du fait
que Dieu
était les créateurs
car ça
c'est quelque part
les bases
que Genèse
veut nous poser
ça commence
avec la présentation
surtout
de qui Dieu est
avec sa toute puissance
au commencement
la création
Genèse 1
au commencement
Dieu
créa
Ok ?
Et donc
même si
l'homme va trouver
une énorme importance
dans la description
de la création
son énorme importance
!
dépend complètement
de l'importance
de Dieu
lui-même
faisons l'homme
notre image
notre assemblance
et donc
à partir de là
on voit
de manière très claire
que rien
que les premiers pactes
que Dieu avait
établis avec l'homme
les pactes
d'oeuvre
donc les choses
dépendaient
quelque part
dans ce que l'homme
pouvait faire
nous voyons
de manière très claire
que déjà
cet acte
de Dieu
de rentrer
dans un pacte
avec l'homme
même par l'échec
de l'homme
pas un échec
mais même par la rébellion
de l'homme
pour les responsabiliser
nous voyons
que ces premiers pactes
définissaient déjà
la structure nécessaire
pour que la rédemption
dans la même structure
d'alliance
puisse être établie
Dieu qui se met
dans une position
des sous-errants
envers
une autre partie
qui était dans une position
des poussières
Dieu nous tire
la poussière
nous met dans son jardin
établit
quelques conditions
pour cette interaction
pour cette réjouissance
en donnant
à l'homme
la possibilité
de rendre
sa position
de manière volontaire
encore plus noble
plus élevée
en ayant
des promesses
ou des sanctions
ou des conséquences
ou des punitions
réservées
si
il n'obéit pas
et c'est notamment
dans ces cadres
dans les cadres
de la punition
de cette première
rébellion
l'homme
en ayant brisé
les pactes
qu'il pourrait
accomplir
dans ces moments-là
c'est que Dieu
va introduire
l'alliance des grâces
il y avait déjà
un aspect des grâces
dans l'alliance
des œuvres
et la structure
que Dieu avait établie
déjà dans l'alliance
des œuvres
c'est la structure
des pactes
d'alliance
qui permet à Dieu
comme on verra plus tard
de développer
les plans de la rédemption
c'est la manière
dont Dieu
peut développer
une relation
avec un être
qui est infiniment
inférieur
à lui-même
c'est la structure
d'alliance
et donc ça évoque
les cadres
originales
ça évoque
la position
élévée de Dieu
et cette
condescendance
de la part
de Dieu
pour exprimer
la possibilité
non seulement
des vies
mais
d'une vie
éternelle
et notamment
à partir
de la chute
de la vie
récupérée
ou la nouvelle
création
et donc
le deuxième paragraphe
il dit
bien plus
puisque l'homme
s'est placé
sous la malédiction
de la loi
par sa chute
il a plus
au Seigneur
de faire
une alliance
des grâces
dans laquelle
il offre
gratuitement
aux pécheurs
la vie
et les saluent
par Jésus Christ
réquérant d'eux
la fin en lui
pour être sauvé
il y promet
en autre
de donner son esprit
à tous ceux
qui sont destinés
à la vie éternelle
pour les rendre
désireux
et capables
de croire
donc jusqu'ici
c'est intéressant
de le remarquer
que tout cela
fait partie
d'un plan
bien organisé
de la part
des dieux
mais l'interaction
nous conduit
envers
les étapes
que nous avons
retrouvées
en Genèse
les pactes
d'oeuvre
les premiers pactes
qui étaient déjà
en acte
des condescendances
des dieux
et à partir
de là
bien plus
la première question
c'est la question
la distance
entre créateur
et créature
impossible
de connexion
comme on y a
un manque
et dieu dans sa
condescendance
établissent un pacte
où il peut
interagir
avec l'être humain
et la deuxième
parle de la distance
à partir de la chute
la distance morale
impossible à l'homme
de surmonter
la distance spirituelle
à partir de la chute
et là à nouveau
c'est Dieu lui-même
qui prend l'initiative
et établit
cette alliance
des grâces
car il n'y avait pas
la possibilité
d'établir
un autre type
d'alliance
une fois que l'homme
n'a plus aucune capacité
de garder
une alliance
basée sur les autres
et donc
un aspect intéressant
à remarquer
dans ces paragraphes
c'est la mention
du fait
qu'il s'agit
d'un pacte
d'une alliance
d'une rédemption
trinitaire
ok
il y a la mention
du Seigneur
du Seigneur Jésus-Christ
il y a la mention
du Saint-Esprit
après on va révéler
sur ces textes
en par an
en lisant
des passages bibliques
dans un autre
leçon
donc ensuite
cette alliance
paragraphe 3
est révé
dans l'évangile
tout d'abord
à Adam
dans la promesse
du salut
par la postérité
de la femme
et par la suite
progressivement
jusqu'à sa révélation
complète
dans les nouveaux
testaments
elle est fondée
dans la transaction
ou dans l'alliance
éternelle
entre les pères
et les fils
concernant
la rédemption
des élus
donc c'est
très important
pour ceux
qui ont été
exposés
en avançant
légèrement
les choses
ceux qui sont
les baptistes
réformés
plus exposés
à la version
la plus populaire
du fédéralisme
si vous voulez
des alliances
c'est très important
de remarquer
l'intentionnalité
des auteurs
ici
de garder
les premiers
baptistes
puritans
cet aspect
d'une seule
alliance
qu'elle a
une seule
alliance
des grâces
qu'elle a
et l'aspect
progressif
de cette révélation
donc
elle est fondée
dans l'alliance
éternelle
entre les pères
et les fils
concernant la rédemption
des élus
ce n'est qu'est
par la grâce
de cette alliance
que tout membre
de la postérité
d'Adam déchu
a jamais été sauvé
et a obtenu
la vie
et la bienheureuse
immortalité
puisque maintenant
l'homme est complètement
incapable d'être
accepté par Dieu
dans les conditions
qui étaient valables
pour Adam
dans son état
d'innocence
nous allons revenir
plus tard
pour les implications
que nous verrons
pour les discussions
théologiques
mais pour l'instant
c'est important
de remarquer
quelques aspects
de ces plans
de rédemption
c'est un plan
qui est
un plan éternel
Dieu n'a pas été
pris par surprise
car même avant
donc la question
qu'on doit se poser
est-ce que
quand on parle
d'un plan éternel
d'une alliance
établie avant
la fondation du monde
est-ce qu'on parle
de quelque chose
qui s'est passé
avant la chute
et l'homme
bien sûr
et donc c'est clair
que les plans
de rédemption
n'étaient pas
une réaction
sur laquelle Dieu
a dû réfléchir
après la chute
c'est quelque chose
qui avait été établi
avant la fondation du monde
donc pour faire
la transition
je vous invite
à réouvrir
vos bibles
en Ephésiens
chapitre 1
c'est très intéressant
de remarquer
la structure
d'Ephésiens
quand vous considérez
que
les chapitres 1
d'Ephésiens
c'est comme si
Paul
nous apportait
à la perspective
divine
éternelle
supratemporelle
au-dessus des temps
pour décrire
en fait
les plans
de rédemption
de son peuple élu
et quand on arrive
au chapitre 2
c'est pour démontrer
de quelle manière
dans nos histoires
personnelles
particulières
Dieu va interagir
avec ses élus
pour nous sauver
et le problème
c'est que nous
parfois on essaye
de mélanger ces choses
d'essayer de comprendre
la manière dont Dieu
a décidé les choses
souverainement
avant la fondation du monde
par nos expériences
personnelles
on pense par exemple
au fait que nous
on a vraiment dû
participer
quelque part
à notre salut
car on s'était
vraiment répentis
et on a vraiment
embarrassé
par la foi
l'évangile
ça c'est vrai
c'est la manière
dont les choses
vont se passer
c'est la manière
dont Dieu va mettre
ses plans éternels
en exécution
et nous participons
par contre
cette participation
non seulement
a été prévue
par Dieu
mais Dieu a dû
agir invisiblement
dans notre régénération
la foi ne vient pas
de vous
c'est un don
des dieux
vous comprenez
donc là
Ephésiens chapitre 1
nous allons lire
quelques versets
pour que ça soit clair
quelques bases
des certains
principes
que nous allons identifier
par rapport à ces plans
éternels
verset 3
béni soit les dieux
et les pères
de notre Seigneur
Jésus Christ
qui nous a béni
des toutes bénédictions
spirituelles
dans les lieux célestes
en Jésus Christ
en lui
Dieu nous a élus
avant la fondation
du monde
pour que nous soyons
sans et sans défaut
devant lui
dans son amour
il nous a prédestiné
par Jésus Christ
à être adopté
selon
les descendants
bienveillants
de sa volonté
donc là
les critères
la mesure
n'était pas
quelque chose
des biens
qu'il a trouvé
en nous
dans certains
c'est pas la prévision
que certains
allaient être
plus intelligents
que d'autres
ou allaient aimer
plus Dieu
que d'autres
et qui allaient
accepter l'évangile
et d'autres non
non
en fait c'était
les desseins
et la résolution
de la volonté
divine
pour célébrer
la gloire
de sa grâce
sinon
si il y a
les mondres mérites
dans un choix
humain
il n'y a plus
la grâce
il y a une participation
soit c'est la grâce
absolue de Dieu
glorifiée
à la plénitude
soit
c'est vraiment
les choix
ou l'intelligence humaine
qui nous a accordé
en son bien aimé
donc cette grâce
nous a été accordée
dans son bien aimé
en lui
nous avons
la rédemption
donc remarquez
combien centré
sur Christ
est-ce
il est plein
de rédemption
ok
en lui
Dieu nous a élus
nous avons la rédemption
et remarquez bien
que Christ
ici n'est pas en train
de jouer
un rôle
contraire à la volonté
de Dieu
c'est pas un Christ
qui plaide
contre la volonté
de Dieu
pour nous bénir
c'est un Dieu
qui nous a élus
en Christ
et c'est un Christ
qui a eu le plaisir
de volontairement
faire cette oeuvre
avec les pères
et donc en lui
nous avons
la rédemption
par son sang
les pardons
des péchés
selon la richesse
de sa grâce
remarquez
combien
par grâce
nous voyons
l'emphase biblique
que Dieu a répandu
abondamment
sur nous
en toute sagesse
et intelligence
il nous a fait connaître
les mystères
de sa volonté
les desseins
bienveillants
qu'il s'était
proposé
en lui-même
donc là
à nouveau
cette phrase
que je trouve
glorieuse
qui dit
Dieu
n'est pas
en train
de chercher
en dehors
de soi
des raisons
pour nous aimer
la raison
c'est de ces puits
infinis
des grâces
qu'il trouve
au-dedans
de lui-même
c'est au-dedans
de lui
de sa propre vertu
qu'il trouve
des raisons
pour aimer
une race péchérèse
comme la nôtre
et donc
qui s'était proposé
en lui
pour exécuter
quand les temps
seraient accomplis
donc remarquez bien
un autre aspect important
sur lequel
on va revenir après
donc un timing
parfait
un plan
parfaitement
planifié
dans ses détails
par anticipation
d'exécuter
lorsqu'il est
temps
s'est accompli
de réunir
sous un seul chef
les Christs
tout ce qui est
dans les cieux
et ce qui est sur la terre
donc
un plan
qui concerne
non seulement
les élus
mais à partir
du moment
où tous ceux
qui ont été adoptés
seront révélés
la révélation finale
Romain chapitre 8
des enfants
des dieux
c'est l'attente
de toute la création
toute la création
veut
elle a été
dévenue otage
à cause de notre rébellion
et elle attend
en jouant son rôle
pour l'instant
elle attend
la rédemption
de tous les élus
tous les enfants
des dieux
pour que toute
la création
soit aussi
restaurée
avec nous
en lui
nous avons aussi
été mis à part
prédestinés
selon les plans
de celui
qui opère
toutes les choses
selon
la manière
dont il réagit
aux choses
qui peuvent
les surprendre
selon
les décisions
de certains hommes
de réjeter
ou embrasser
l'évangile
non
selon celui
qui opère
tout
selon
la décision
ou les conseils
de sa volonté
afin que nous
servions
à célébrer
sa gloire
donc
qui sert
à célébrer
la gloire
des dieux
nous
qui d'avance
avons espéré
en Jésus Christ
en lui
vous aussi
après avoir entendu
la parole
de la vérité
et là c'est
l'interaction
dans nos vies
personnelles
l'évangile
de votre salut
en lui
vous avez cru
et vous avez été
scellé
du Saint-Esprit
qui avait été
promis
donc à nouveau
Dieu le Père
Dieu le Fils
Dieu le Saint-Esprit
et qui constitue
les gages
de notre héritage
en vue de la rédemption
de ceux
qui Dieu
s'est acquis
pour célébrer
sa gloire
donc ce texte
il met en emphase
je pense que c'est un texte
il va rassembler
les plus
tous les éléments
de ces trois paragraphes
de la confession
qu'on a lu
on voit
les aspects
de la participation
des trois personnes
de la Trinité
on voit l'aspect éternel
de ces pactes
entre les personnes
de la Trinité
et notamment
entre les Pères
et les Fils
et la manière
dont cette structure
pactuelle
éternelle
va déterminer
la relation
et l'interaction
des dieux
avec les êtres humains
et donc quand on est
en train de constater
et ça c'est très important
déjà pour anticiper
un élément important
dans la considération
du rôle
de chaque
révélation progressive
du rôle
de chaque
alliance
qui nous est révélée
elles n'ont jamais
la même force
nous n'avons pas besoin
c'est comme pour les mariages
les mariages
qui Dieu nous a donnés
il a un suture
il a des catégories
mais
Dieu n'a pas
regardé les mariages
il a dit
voici quelque chose
d'intéressant
pour illustrer
ma relation
avec l'église
non c'est le contraire
il avait
considéré
cette relation
maritale
entre Christ
et son épouse
l'église
et sur la base
de quelque chose
de plus sublime
il a révélé
et donné
aux hommes
une relation
similaire
inférieure
vous comprenez
et donc
ces alliances
nous ne pouvons pas
dépendre
d'une progression
dans la structure
des certaines alliances
on ne peut pas regarder
par exemple
l'alliance
historique
dans l'ancienne alliance
qui avait
plus d'éléments
c'était notamment
l'alliance
mosaïque
mais cela ne veut pas dire
que nous dépendons
de tous ces éléments
et enrégir
notre compréhension
de l'alliance
en disant
il faut que la continuité
des choses soit
exactement pareille
à cette révélation
car
elle est fondée
avant tout
sur les plans éternels
et déjà
quand Dieu va traiter
l'alliance d'Abraham
Paul
au Galate
il va dire clairement
que cette alliance
qui était moins formelle
et plus essentielle
dans sa formalité
elle était déjà parfaite
avec Abraham
avant la circoncision
et avant même
d'avoir un descendant
donc ça c'est très important
quand on va établir
les bases
et les catégories
quand on va considérer
ces questions
plus théologiques
je vais reprendre plus tard
mais c'est important
de remarquer
la référence suprême
c'est cette alliance
ou ce pacte éternel
entre les pères
les fils
et les saints esprits
et donc
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
encore aujourd'hui
pour la suite
j'ai encore
quelques minutes
je vais juste
en suivant
bien sûr
la proposition
de Lloyd-Jones
considérer
quelques principes
qui vont définir
cette rédemption
donc
je ne vais pas
rentrer encore
dans
dans l'exploit
théologique
de la conception
d'alliance
mais elle fera partie
de la compréhension
de cette question
qui est plus importante
pour nous
qui est la révélation
du grand plan
des dieux
des rédemptions
ok
donc
je vais vous présenter
quelques principes
qui caractérisent
cette rédemption
divine
si vous voulez
c'est une introduction
au grand plan
de la rédemption
des dieux
je vous ai anticipé
par lecture
d'Ephésiens
quelques de ses points
mais
si vous voulez noter
la première chose
ce qu'on a remarqué
c'est que nous sommes
ça c'est pas encore
l'enprunt
mais nous sommes
devant les thèmes
qui prennent
la plupart des écritures
ok
création glorieuse
les bases établies
on ne peut pas douter
de l'historicité
littéralité
des jeunesses
géolittérales
etc
donc à partir de là
on considère la chute
aussi historique
même les serpents
qui parlent
etc
historique
important
les bases ont été posées
et ensuite
la Bible
elle va traiter
du développement
de ces points
de rédemption
c'est ce qui va occuper
la plupart des écritures
et donc
c'est
si vous voulez
l'oeuvre
principale
des dieux
c'est la nouvelle création
même si on considère
la gloire
de la création
comme disaient
les puritans
ça va exiger
infiniment
plus d'énergie
et de puissance
de la part des dieux
pour ressusciter
l'homme
pour régénérer
ça va prendre
son fils
donc un théologien
il a dit
pour créer
l'humanité
Dieu a eu besoin
de sa parole puissante
mais pour récréer
l'humanité
Dieu a besoin
d'employer
son propre fils
la parole
les verbes
les logos lui-même
et donc c'est là
où on doit concentrer
nos égards
donc la première chose
qu'on doit
catégoriquement
affirmer
c'est
que ce salut
est entièrement
cette rédemption
de la part
de l'initiative
divine
c'est une oeuvre
des dieux
ce n'est pas
l'oeuvre
de l'homme
quelqu'un a déjà proposé
que la bible
elle est quelque part
l'enregistrement
notamment l'ancien testament
d'un homme
qui essaye de faire
des efforts
envers dieux
et notamment
sous l'influence
de l'autre critique
de l'évolutionnisme
quand on a voulu
discréditer
l'enregistrement historique
des jeunesses
on disait
là c'est vraiment
des essais
humants
pour s'approcher
des dieux
et ce qu'on va trouver
dans la bible
c'est notamment
les contraires
c'est l'homme
qui va se révéler
contre dieux
qui va vouloir
fuir des dieux
et c'est dieux lui-même
qui prend
l'initiative
pour aller
vers l'homme
donc
la bible
n'est pas
une question
non plus
de ce que l'homme
essaye de faire
pour apaiser dieux
car certains
vont chercher
à décrire la religion
comme des efforts
humains
pour apaiser dieux
ce qu'on doit faire
ce qu'on doit performer
pour essayer
de diminuer
même la juge scolaire divine
contre nous
et ça
c'est pas du tout
la manière dont la bible
nous explique
les plans de rédemption
des dieux
donc
certainement
en mourant
vous mourrez
la charge
et la place
des dieux
ok
en tant que
juge
suprême
en tant que créateur
c'est
à partir du moment
où l'homme devient
en pureté
c'est tout simplement
la nécessité sur dieux
d'effacer l'humanité
de punir l'humanité
de lancer l'humanité
à l'enfer
mais
qui va apaiser
dieux lui-même
donc bien sûr
que l'homme
essaye
de se couvrir
mais c'était pas suffisant
pour apaiser dieux
avec les feuilles
et c'est dieux lui-même
qui va
trouver des éléments
et une manière
d'illustrer
la vraie manière
dont il sera apaisé
donc c'est dieux lui-même
qui va s'apaiser
en faisant
son plan de rédemption
et ça on voit
déjà
dans les cadres
du récit
des jeunesses
qu'on a lu
au début
ce n'est pas non plus
la considération
d'un Christ
comme je vous ai dit
qui essaye
lui-même
d'apaiser Dieu
contre sa volonté
à nouveau
on vient de lire
en Ephésiens
c'est en lui
Dieu nous a élus
en lui
Dieu a décidé
de pourvoir
l'expiation
pour nous
en Christ
et Christ lui-même
il est en train
d'accomplir
l'oeuvre
que les pères
lui avaient donné
donc là aussi
nous voir une manière
très claire
dans la parole
de Dieu
c'est une oeuvre
entièrement
divine
et donc nous voyons
comment
2e Corinthiens 5
nous dit
que Christ
Dieu était un Christ
réconciliant les mondes
avec soi-même
donc c'est Dieu
qui vient
non seulement
Dieu
il est là
pour nous accepter
si on vient
répandir devant sa présence
il est là
pour nous chercher
pour nous procurer
quelque part
et nous réconcilier
avec lui
et c'est démoniaque
de céder
à cette considération
d'être constamment
devant Dieu
contre nous
Dieu a des raisons
pour être contre nous
mais envers ses élus
c'est Dieu lui-même
qui vient vers nous
qui pourvoit les moyens
c'est lui qui vient
déjà
devant
devant Adam
pour nous parler
du plan
de la rédemption
des protéévangiles
et donc
le deuxième principe
qu'on va considérer
à propos de cette rédemption
c'est que
la rédemption divine
elle est totalement
par grâce
ok
donc la Bible
elle nous dit
clairement
donc on vient
de lire
Ephésiens
et Ephésiens
chapitre 2
il va dire
de manière encore
plus catégorique
car c'est par la grâce
que vous êtes sauvés
par les moyens
de la foi
c'est un Dieu
qui fait toutes les choses
selon la richesse
de sa grâce
selon les conseils
de sa propre volonté
et donc
les saluts
étant dons
immérités
donc en dépit
de la rébellion
de l'homme
en dépit
de l'arrogance
de l'homme
en dépit
de la folie
de notre péché
de nos péchés
on voit
à chaque fois
c'est
mais Dieu
de quelle manière
nous contribuons
à notre salut
avec les péchés
avec la condamnation
et Dieu
il a cette
cette conjonction
d'adversité
mais Dieu
c'est lui
qui est venu
vers nous
et qui nous a appelé
à nouveau
lorsqu'on a tourné
les deux
contre lui
donc c'est la grâce
incomparable
et glorieuse
de Dieu
c'est
comme on avait vu déjà
c'est la vertu
ou l'attribut
des dieux
ou la facette
c'est l'amour
des dieux
ok
qui devrait être
la mère
de toutes les vertus
pour nous
c'est la faveur
imméritée des dieux
et donc c'est
cet amour
contre conditionnel
c'est la grâce
des dieux
qui nous assure
et donc
la rédemption
elle est complètement
par la grâce
totalement
par grâce
toute notion
d'éméritement
doit être exclu
de ces plans
de rédemption
une autre chose
qu'on va constater
dans les récits
du proto-évogile
cette première promesse
des pardons
de réconciliation
et notamment
en Ephésiens
qui fait une description
plus précise
c'est
que ces plans
de rédemption
ont été planifiés
avant
la fondation
du monde
donc il n'y a
aucune surprise
nous
lorsqu'on a
cette réalité
de notre vie
cette expérience
donc on oublie
en fait
que lorsque Dieu
a créé
l'univers
il a créé
toutes ces catégories
des temps
espace
matière
donc au commencement
Dieu créa
les ciels
et la terre
donc commencement
a commencé
lorsque Dieu
a créé
cet univers
mais pour Dieu
il n'y a pas
des commencements
de fin
il vit dans
une réalité
supratemporelle
et donc c'est
impossible même
par divinité
par un attribut
divin
que les temps
puissent mettre
des rayures
dans les visages
de très haut
donc on voit
de manière très claire
que cette rédemption
elle faisait partie
du plan parfait
des dieux
dès le départ
Dieu se trouve
en dehors du temps
et Ephésiens
il nous dit
de manière très claire
en lui
ou en Christ
Dieu nous a élus
avant la fondation
du monde
ok
donc il n'y a rien
qui prend Dieu
par surprise
ça met en emphase
cette sagesse divine
un autre aspect
qu'on a constaté
aussi en Ephésiens
et nous voyons aussi
des manières
un peu plus embryonnaires
ou un peu
moins explicites
dans la chute
d'Adam et elle
c'est lorsque Dieu dit
que du descendant
de la fin
viendra un
et plus tard
on va apprendre
que c'est tant
qu'il viendra
c'est l'incarnation
du fils
mais
l'aspect pluriel
dont l'homme
a été créé
en jeunesse
nous donnent déjà
des indices
que l'homme
a été créé
à l'image
de la trinité
faisons-nous
l'homme
notre image
notre assemblance
mais c'est intéressant
de remarquer
par les développements
et d'identifier
en fait
que les trois personnes
de la trinité
donc c'est les points
quatre pour nous
les trois personnes
de la trinité
de la sainte trinité
ont pris part
à ces plans
et c'est à partir
de là aussi
que nous voyons
cette suture
formelle
d'alliance
par l'alliance
des natures divines
et par l'alliance
qui est Dieu établie
pour ce qui concerne
son interaction
avec l'être humain
donc les pères
doivent toujours
garder sa position
dans un univers
sans un Dieu trinitaire
il n'y a pas d'espoir
pour l'humanité
car l'homme
en tant que créature
pourrait garder
sa condition
s'il n'avait jamais tombé
et une fois qu'il a tombé
il a besoin
d'être préservé
et Dieu ne peut pas
préserver
sans expier
la faute humaine
et en même temps
pour expier
la faute humaine
il faut trouver
un nouveau représentant
pour toute la race
et ce nouveau représentant
ne peut pas être trouvé
entre les hommes
car tous les hommes
sont corrompus
et donc il va falloir
que Dieu
prenne la forme humaine
sauf que si Dieu
prend la forme humaine
et il n'est pas
un Dieu trinitaire
il va délaisser
sa place des juges
et il n'y aurait pas
non plus un avocat
qui a les rôles
de Saint-Esprit
quelque part
pour appliquer
pour exécuter
ces plans
donc là
on voit
de manière parfaite
comment
cette suture
d'alliance
des natures
divines même
va être importante
dans la révélation
biblique
du plan éternel
des dieux
pour notre rédemption
donc les pères
ils planifient
ils gardent sa position
d'autorité suprême
des juges suprêmes
et ils donnent
un peuple
au fils
ok
donc il fait
du fils
les nouveaux
représentants
de cette race
les fils
vont accomplir
ce qu'il doit
accomplir
en tant qu'il
représentant
de la race humaine
et il va
devenir
les médiateurs
parfaits
car une fois
que maintenant
c'est les fils
des dieux
qui deviendront
les médiateurs
de la race humaine
la race humaine
serait quelque part
élevée aussi
à une position
encore plus élevée
dans sa relation
avec Dieu
son médiateur
est divin
quelque part
même s'il doit
être humain
pour expier nos fautes
sa personne divine
élève aussi
notre relation
avec Dieu
donc les fils
vont accomplir
et devenir
les médiateurs
et les chèques
de la nouvelle alliance
et le Saint-Esprit
va appliquer
et sceller
va mettre en exécution
l'application
et les fruits
de cette rédemption
va rendre expérimentale
et réelle
cette rédemption
c'est lui
qui opère
la régénération
et qui opère
cette expérience
des conversions
et qui fait
habitation
pour nous sceller
et donc on voit
qu'il y a donc
dans la Bible
cette économie
qu'on appelle
de la rédemption
dans l'oeuvre
du salut
mais même
si on peut noter
les rôles
des trois personnes
de la Trinité
et l'engagement
volontaire
des trois personnes
de la Trinité
c'est aussi
particulièrement intéressant
de remarquer
comment il y a
une interaction
et c'est ça
qui est glorieux
par la perspective
divine entre Trinité
entre ces pactes
particuliers
qu'il est père
en train de faire
envers les fils
car il y a une fonction
pour les Saint-Esprits
à jouer
mais cette interaction
plus directe
plus proche
est plus facilement
remarquable
par sa récourance
dans la parole
des dieux
par plusieurs perspectives
lorsqu'on voit
par exemple
depuis
les
voilà
les hébreux
chapitres 1
versets 1 et 2
qui vont présenter
les fils
comme les premiers nés
ou
Célie qui va
hériter
toute la création
donc
ça remonte
aussi
dans notre passage
au fait
que la parole
était Dieu
la parole
était avec Dieu
et par la parole
toutes les choses
ont été faites
donc même si Dieu
est les propriétaires
ultimes
les créateurs
de toutes les choses
il a créé
toutes les choses
à travers les fils
il a donné
toutes les choses
au fils
il a fait converger
toutes les choses
au fils
mais particulièrement
les biens
les plus précieux
pour Dieu
d'entre toute la création
c'est l'église
c'est la race humaine
rachetée
et cette église
a été confiée
particulièrement
ou donnée
au fils
démande de moi
psaume 2
et j'ai été
donnerai
les nations
pour héritage
l'intercession
sacerdotale
du fils
c'est pour ceux
qui les père
lui a donné
l'oeuvre
particulière
qu'il était
en train d'exécuter
à la croix
c'était pour ceux
qui Dieu
l'avait donnée
voilà pourquoi
on parle
de cette expiation
efficace
car cette expiation
elle a été faite
pour un peuple
défini
donc nous voulons
de manière très claire
que ces peuples
qui les père
a donné au fils
et qui nous concernent
par pure grâce divine
et on ne pose pas
la question
même si on peut
le poser
pourquoi pas les autres
mais on doit poser
avant tout
et d'abord
pourquoi moi
car moi
je me trouve aussi
d'entre les rebelles
et donc
c'est important
pour nous
de considérer
cet aspect
trinitaire
et particulièrement
cette relation
entre les pères
et les fils
par le fait
que Dieu a donné
au fils
toutes les choses
et particulièrement
par le fait
que les pères
a fait du fils
les représentants
d'une nouvelle humanité
donc les parallèles
entre Adam
et Christ
les nouvelles Adam
Romain 5
nous nous rappelons
de manière très claire
quand la Bible parle
ceux qui sont en Christ
nouvelles
créations
dans les littérales
c'est ça qui est
vraiment super
c'est tout
en étant fait
converger
dans les fils
et l'unité
de chaque nouvelle créature
que nous sommes
en étant
un Christ
ok
donc nous sommes
en Jésus Christ
car
il a porté
sur sa patrine
en tant que suprême
sacrificateur
les noms
du dade
de chacun d'entre nous
mais nous sommes tous
en lui
la nouvelle création
donc tout est
condensé
en Jésus Christ
donc il est
les médiateurs
de la nouvelle alliance
et ensuite
les pères
donnent au fils
tous ceux
qu'ils ressusciteraient
donc on voit
la précision
la particularité
de ceux
qui les pères
a donné au fils
tous ceux
qu'ils ressusciteraient
dans les derniers jours
donc là
on va retrouver
cette conception
en Jésus 6
et aussi la même idée
en Jésus 17
pardon
dans sa prière sacerdotale
et bien sûr
les textes publiques
nous parlent
à plusieurs reprises
lorsqu'il crie
se va dire
dans sa prière sacerdotale
j'ai glorifié
j'étais glorifié
sur la terre
en ayant consommé
l'oeuvre
qui tu m'as donné
à faire
c'est à dire
il avait une oeuvre
très spécifique
les fils avaient reçu
de la part de père
qu'il devrait
accomplir
et donc ça montre
de manière encore
plus claire
et précise
l'interaction
entre les pères
et les fils
et même
jusqu'au psaume 40
et hébreu 10
verset 5
qui nous parle
que jusqu'à préparer
les corps
du Christ
c'était la préparation
que les pères
avaient fait
et qui montre
vraiment
ces pactes trinitaires
dans plusieurs aspects
très intéressants
donc le cinquième aspect
c'est l'aspect
d'un descend
très défini
ce plan
a été
un schéma
un suture
qui était
très défini
sans la moindre
possibilité
des fautes trouvées
d'impossibilité
des surprises
et tout cela
nous voyons
par la précision
de l'accomplissement
prophétique
qui touche
à notre rédemption
et par cette révélation
progressive
de chaque pacte
quand on pense
à Abraham
nous voyons
comment Dieu
disait déjà
Abraham
que c'était
un descendant
qui viendrait
et c'est intéressant
le langage
de Paul au Galate
qui dit
que la promesse
a été faite
pas à Abraham
mais en Abraham
la promesse
a été faite
à qui ?
à Christ
la promesse
a été faite
au descendant
d'Abraham
que toutes les nations
seraient bénies
en lui
et donc ça
c'est glorieux
car Abraham
a été béni
comme un modèle
du Christ
un symbole
un type
mais la promesse
a été faite
au fils
et ceux
de la descendance
d'Abraham
ce sont ceux
de la foi
ce sont les élus
et donc c'est là
on voit une manière
très claire
qui est lorsqu'il a fait
cette promesse
d'Abraham
il avait déjà dit
Abraham
qu'à 400 ans
les peuples
resteraient en Égypte
précision chronologique
ensuite
on voit la même chose
par rapport à Noé
quand il fait
cette alliance
avec Noé
et Noé
a l'impression
que les choses
tardent
etc
et Dieu
donne le temps
déterminé
que les choses
allaient se passer
dans l'arche
nous voyons surtout
la même chose
quand on vient de lire
en Éphésiens
lorsqu'il est temps
été accompli
et les passages
qu'on a dans l'Éphésiens
en parlant
du temps
vous avez ouvert encore
l'Éphésiens 1
lorsque les temps
s'est accompli
on a envoyé son fils
super
et Galat chapitre 4
c'est ce texte
qui est dans ma tête
où il dit
en arrivant
à la plénitude
des temps
Dieu a envoyé
son fils
né d'une femme
né sous la loi
et donc là
ça parle aussi
de manière très claire
et certains disent
que peut-être
que Dieu a beaucoup
tardé
pourquoi il a pris
si longtemps
etc
Lloyd-Jones
il partage
une idée
très intéressante
je suis complètement
d'accord
c'est que Dieu
avait donné
et ça c'est très lié
aussi à la manière
dont Paul va parler
de cette période
didatique
aussi
pour Israël
comme un enfant
de la liberté
d'un Seigneur
mais qui pendant
qu'il est encore jeune
il est traité
comme un esclave
pour que de manière
très didatique
il soit entraîné
envers les bonnes choses
et de l'autre côté
toutes les nations
et d'entre les nations
les élus
des dieux aussi
qui seraient sauvés
donc Paul est en train
on parlait des Galates
qui étaient gardés
dans la perdition totale
dans l'esclavage total
des religions humaines
et c'est intéressant
car
Lloyd-Jones
il va dire
c'était nécessaire
pour l'humanité
d'avoir beau essayer
toutes ces manières
incorrectes
d'apaiser Dieu
ou de trouver
sa relation avec Dieu
sa rédemption
dans cette histoire
et de constater
à chaque fois
que l'homme
se trouvait
dans une condition
de complet besoin
que Dieu fasse quelque chose
donc dans les cas d'Israël
c'était toute cette didatique
mosaïque
qui était nécessaire
pour convaincre du péché
du besoin absolu
du Christ
impossible d'accomplir la loi
par les oeuvres de la chair
ou par les efforts de la chair
et de l'autre côté
toutes les nations païennes
complètement livrées
aux passions
et aux religions
corrompues
et même
Lloyd-Jones va mentionner
toutes les philosophes
avec les mieux
que l'humanité
aurait pu produire
en termes de pensée
qui n'arrivaient pas
à trouver
la réponse ultime
ou les logos
et voilà pourquoi
on a ces quatre érogies
qui vont s'adresser
à tous les aspects
universels
des demandes
et des essayements
de trouver la vérité
ou la réponse
et donc la Bible
est très claire
donc il y a un passage
qui montre
cet orchestre divine
quand on voit par exemple
les textes qui disent
que
quand les pharisiens
et scribes
ils ont commencé
à planifier
la mort du Christ
ils se sont dit
entre eux
on va faire
d'une certaine manière
qu'ils ne soient pas crucifiés
pendant la Pâque
et on voit
toute l'intentionnalité
pour qu'ils ne soient pas
crucifiés pendant la Pâque
et on voit comment
à l'heure parfaite
ils non seulement
ont pu de manière légitime
célébrer la Pâque
selon les Galiléens
et en même temps
être crucifiés
pendant la Pâque
selon ceux de Jérusalem
et donc c'est tout simplement
glorieux
de voir
les timings parfaits
des dieux
dans ces plans
de rédemption
et donc on voit
de manière très claire
que c'était un plan
défini parfaitement
et voilà pourquoi
son efficacité
est aussi parfaite
les plans définis
et les résultats aussi
et donc voilà pourquoi
les prochains attributs
c'est celui
de la certitude absolue
de la consommation
de ces plans
non seulement
par la déclaration
du Christ
à la croix
tout est accompli
mais par l'assurance
de l'efficacité
du salut
de tous les élus
et la croissance
de l'église
etc
et donc on a
cette fermeté
cette assurance
qu'aucun de ceux
qui les perdent
à confier au fils
ne sera laissé
abandonné
et ne va pas être sauvé
et pourrait
se perdre
de sa main
car Dieu
tient dans sa main
les fils
et il nous scelle
de son esprit
tout puissant
donc le septième aspect
je vais avancer
un peu plus vite
c'est que les buts
des dieux
dans cette rédemption
concernent non seulement
l'être humain
mais aussi
toutes les choses
Dieu a fait converger
en Christ
toutes les choses
réunir en Christ
dans les cieux
et dans la terre
en lisant
Ephésiens chapitre 1
on a déjà évoqué ça
mais c'est important
pour nous
de nous rappeler
que ces plans
des rédemptions
concernent
la totalité
de la création
mon avant-dernier point
c'est que
ces plans
des rédemptions
sont toujours
centrés
sur les seigneurs
Jésus-Christ
donc là
dans les passages
d'Ephésiens
on a vu
à chaque fois
on a été élus
en lui
il nous a prédestinés
pour les bonnes oeuvres
en lui
et c'est recourant
non seulement
dans la théologie
de l'apôtre de Paul
mais dans les enseignements
du Christ lui-même
il est la vigne
et donc ces plans
de rédemption
il a pour but
nous réconcilier
avec Dieu
sans qu'on ne perde
jamais de vue
qui nous sommes
réconciliés
avec Dieu
en Jésus-Christ
quelle est la première
implication de ça
l'une des plus glorieuses
pour nous
c'est que
les mêmes affections
que Dieu a
pour son fils
sont les affections
que Dieu dépose sur nous
que les mêmes mérites
que Christ a conquis
par son œuvre parfaite
nous assurent
la bénédiction pleine
pour toujours
pendant toute l'éternité
malgré les faibles
souffrances
pour plus douloureuses
qu'elles soient
ça va être très vite
cette vie
et on va vivre
toute une éternité
en étant béni
à tous égards
dans la présence de Dieu
car il n'y a aucune conquête
que Christ a fait
en termes de mérite
pour que les bénédictions
on est déjà bénis
dans les régions célestes
de toutes les bénédictions
spirituelles
nous sommes déjà
en train d'hériter
toutes les choses
on est déjà en Christ
notre vie est cachée
en Christ
dans les lieux célestes
et la réalité
la plus véritable
à propos de nous
de notre identité
aujourd'hui
c'est que nous sommes cachés
en Christ
donc lorsque Dieu
va nous regarder
si nous sommes un Christ
il va contempler avant tout
la beauté de son fils
et ses affections
sont dirigées envers nous
comme si elles sont
dirigées à Christ
et bien sûr
que par une perspective
d'assurance
c'est la chose
ou la méditation
la plus glorieuse
et bien sûr
que ça ne fait qu'enrichir
la gloire du Christ lui-même
et donc d'être un Christ
c'est des pouvoirs
considérés
qui en ayant notre vie
cachée en lui
notre proximité
avec lui
en étant habitation
de son esprit
nous permet
de réjouir
de la beauté
de celui
qui est
l'être le plus aimable
de l'univers
il est
l'objet
de l'adoration
suprême des anges
il est
l'objet
des affections
suprêmes
du père
et donc on ne doit pas
penser tout simplement
au bénéfice
qu'on peut avoir
pour être un Christ
des bénédictions
qu'on va recevoir
de la part des dieux
mais on doit penser
à cette grâce
et proximité
de voir que ces plans
de rédemption
sont centrés sur Christ
pour que la révélation
suprême
de la gloire des dieux
de l'amour des dieux
de l'amabilité des dieux
soit trouvée
par les plans
de rédemption
car dans les plans
nous avons une idée
non seulement
du fait que Dieu est amour
et que Dieu nous aime
mais l'intensité
comme Christian a bien exposé
les dimanches derniers
l'intensité
de l'amour des dieux
qui est mesurée
par l'amabilité
de celui
qu'il a donné pour nous
l'amabilité du fils
on doit se plonger
comme au quantique
chapitre 5
il est aimable
totalement aimable
dans son ensemble
il est totalement aimable
dans ses facettes
chaque vertu du Christ
la symétrie du Christ
quand on contemple
les écritures
lorsqu'il était en train
d'accomplir
l'oeuvre de rédemption
il a manifesté
l'humilité
condescendante
de celui
qui a donné sa vie
à la croix
pour nous
et en même temps
il a démontré
la noblesse
et la toute puissance
de sa résurrection
donc en la croix
on voit la justice
parfaite des dieux
la grâce parfaite des dieux
les contrastes
l'harmonie
entre ses vertus
glorieuses des dieux
à l'infini
et donc Christ
il devient donc
les centres
car il devient
la révélation suprême
de ses vertus
glorieuses des dieux
de l'amour des dieux
et le dernier aspect
c'est le fait
que cette
rédemption
a pour but
pardon
cette rédemption
qui a été révélée
à l'humanité
elle a été révélée
à travers
une structure
d'alliance
et ça aussi
on verra
les bénéfices
pour nous
immédiats
donc c'est
cette sécurité
qu'on a
par les 100 versets
qui scelle cette alliance
mais
il a été révélé
par une structure
d'alliance
à travers
plusieurs
alliances
et ça
sera l'objet
de notre intérêt
de nos études
pour les prochaines
leçons
on va considérer
l'importance
de cette alliance
même si j'ai déjà
anticipé certains points
mais c'est important
de remarquer
que c'est un constat
inévitable
à chaque fois
qu'on regarde
la manière dont Dieu
a révélé la rédemption
depuis les proto-évangiles
les descendants
de la fin
etc
on a des éléments
d'alliances
qui sont retrouvés
et c'est important
pour nous d'enrichir
notre compréhension
du plan de rédemption
car ce plan de rédemption
a lieu
dans un cadre
des relations
entre Dieu et Homme
qui est un cadre
d'alliance
et c'est un cadre